from screen junkie studios in the Heart
of Los Angeles this is screen junkies
movie fights now your host Andy signor
greetings screen junkies and welcome to
another awesome episode of movie fights
I'm so excited to have this wonderful
panel and we're going to be fighting
some amazing fights today including cast
the all male Ghostbusters reboot who
should direct the next mission
impossible movie which was already
apparently they're already working on
MI6 which I'm kind of excited for
because I liked MI5 a lot uh also
pitched the final hu Jackman movie he
went to Twitter Hugh Jackman said how do
you want to see Wolverine go out we're
going to have our panelists tell us how
they see it happening as always if you
don't like a battle or you're not
interested in it don't leave just skip
it bottom right hand corner you can pick
your fight and go on to the next fight
so please stay tuned you can't do that
sadly on iTunes but you can listen to us
on iTunes so please go subscribe to our
RSS feed comment rate subscribe all that
stuff they do on iTunes uh I think it's
similar to YouTube but please show us
some love there we appreciate it all
right let's meet our Gladiators for
today today's Fighters are Chloe dyra
actress host and cosplayer first time
fighter Trisha herburger YouTuber and
actress third
appearance Alicia Malone co-host of
profiles three
wins I love that guitar solo Oh welcome
guys that's a good intro right first up
Alicia Malone three wins man you I
that's I I forgot you're you're crushing
it these days are you probably making
these people nervous you to be back I'm
nervous I mean apologies for these eye
bags I barely got any sleep last night
cuz these two ladies have serious geek
cred so I am not expecting an easy fight
at all they do and I'm excited I'm
excited to have you here miss kloe dyri
from uh uh you're working on cosplay
closet and Escapist so much more cool
stuff thanks for being here we're happy
fans were requesting you I'm so glad we
could finally make you Ser oh that makes
me feel special what also makes me feel
special is hearing my name in that voice
epic voice man ever John Bailey knows
how to make it all sound Epic no I agree
it's so fun he does my voicemail I'm so
happy has a soundtrack and everything
and next to Trisha I'm so glad to have
Trisha herburger you're so much stuff
you're going on at Escapist you're Hing
super fan builds take my money so much
fun stuff you're busy so much fun stuff
yeah super busy um but definitely happy
to be here again I feel like it is
finally my time hopefully I don't know I
you you ladies definitely are going to
bring it and I'm a little nervous but
I'm I'm feeling I'm feeling positive
today I think it was my cup of coffee I
don't know something so as Rebecca Black
so as Rebecca Black s this is your
moment
yes it has to be Rebecca Black I don't
know it's the one I remember okay sorry
it could also be not Friday Friday yeah
Friday's the more I'm I'm a serious
Rebecca Black fan because I pull her
second single out bide time I've ever
heard that I didn't even know she had a
did a viral we did a viral video where
we did the no autotune look it up my
moment no autotune that were it was it
did very well but I've listened to that
song a million times that's why I'm not
I love Rebecca Black I am a fan sorry
next up on the fan cam we're glad to
have back it's Miss movies hey I'm here
uh you this is your second appearance in
the fan cam we're happy we're happy to
have you and you brought treats again if
you guys haven't didn't see or didn't
have uh homemade fudge wow thank you I'm
really hoping that I don't have a minute
of screen time from jte this time that
was really embarrassing that was very
strange last time JT like sort of kept
you on for about 20 seconds too long and
we're way too long I mean of course it's
always great to have you on camera but
there we were talking and you weren't
talking and it was a little but JT props
to JT in the booth y JT and Jason behind
the scenes crew we love you guys thank
you for the help all right guys what do
you say should we get to this you guys
know the rules how this works Chloe
you're new let me remind you I'm basing
no matter what YouTube and Twitter tells
me they're wrong I'm basing this on your
arguments so you got to tell me why your
movie is the best and why theirs isn't
it's about facts passion creativity uh
tell me why and that's what going to
make you win uh any questions is there
like a guy that's going to come around
give us backrubs between the rounds or
we should figure that out maybe Jason
no he just shrugs all right let's do
this okay now let's do this this is
where we
fight fight fight round
one I drew here screenwriter confirm
that there's a script being developed
for a male Ghostbusters movie alongside
Paul Fig's all female Ghostbusters which
would eventually lead into an Avengers
like Crossover with both Ghostbusters
team it seems like a lot of Ghostbusters
but whatever Ivan ryman's denying this
we don't know if it's true or not but we
thought this would be a fun fight we
actually did this in our very first
movie fights we had our panelists pitch
their female Ghostbusters cast we now
know officially who they are but I
thought this might be fun for us today J
Bowman 98 agreed and he asked on Twitter
cast The maale Ghostbusters reboot movie
um Tatum and Pratt were the studios uh
those are the ones the rumored the
studio wants you can use those anybody
you want but Alicia we're starting with
you and I think we have some visual aids
to help we can ceue up your team why
don't we see who Alicia's pi were and
you tell us okay presenting the most
awesome Ghostbusters team around with
Channing Tatum Joel male Michael Pena
and Bobby Monahan wow now the thing that
I loved about the original Ghostbusters
was how different each of the four guys
were but they all worked together so
well they had different comedic energies
but somehow it worked so that's what I
thought about when I was casting my team
so starting with Channing Tatum he's the
guy that the studio wants he most likely
will produce the film as well but beyond
that he has such a likeability on screen
and a great comedic Talent we've seen
that with 21 Jump Street and I love when
he plays these really sweet innocent
characters so that's how I imagine him
in this world then to offset that you
have Joel mcale who has such a great
sarcastic sense of humor he's also
someone I feel like needs a bigger shot
in movies he's been great in community
we've seen him in other movies before
but this would really cement him as a
comedic star then you have Michael Pena
who stole Ant-Man for me I thought he
was so funny all his scenes I love the
way he narrated what was happening we've
seen him in comedic movies before as
well as dramas one thing he's good at is
working within a team so I love him and
and and I want to see him do more
comedies after seeing Atman and then
finally like the original Ghostbusters
and like the female version of
Ghostbusters you got to look at Saturday
Night Live for the next big comedic
talent and I love Bobby Monahan I think
he is the the best male cast member they
have at the moment uh he steals the show
I love a drunk uncle uh he's also really
good at being a supporting player in
sketches so I want to see him do more
movies and together I think all these
guys they fit together they they look
like a good team they're all about the
same age and I can imagine them against
the four female Ghostbusters we have fun
team up Chloe let's see your uh your
your picks okay so my picks I'm so
excited about this I love seeing them
all together so we're going to start off
with Chris Pratt because everybody loves
Chris Chris Pratt I mean if you didn't
put Chris Pratt in this movie everyone
would be super mad about it so then uh
I'm moving on actually most of the guys
are TV stars because I feel like a lot
of TV stars are going to start doing
movies because TV's kind of stealing the
show right now so uh I'll do John
krinski next John krinski is amazing
he's been on the office for like 10
years or something he's just hilarious
he's quirky he's interesting I feel like
he has a a range uh and then I also
pulled from the community pool and I
went with Donald Glover because uh I
absolutely love Donald Glover his
comedic timing is unreal it's he's so
fun to watch I could just watch him do a
show by himself for like an hour and
then finally I went with TJ Miller
because uh I I don't know if you guys
have watched Silicone Valley but he just
kills it and I think he's he's not
underrated because I think everybody
really appreciates him but I think he's
underused and I would love to see him in
the Ghostbusters movie for sure fun cast
so far Trisha let's see your lineup all
right if you're giving me the go-ahead
to cast The Dream Team this is my dream
team it's uh Martin Freeman Benedict
Cumberbatch Dwayne Johnson and Robert
Downey Jr wow right right if you're
giving me free reign of all of Hollywood
this is who I'm going with um I think
that much like Alicia said it's how the
guys play off each other that's so
wonderful and if this is a reboot and
not a continuation I think if it ain't
broke don't fix it let's not change the
formula we need two Geeks a slacker and
a guy who just needs a job um so I want
to really embody what we love so much
about the original Ghostbusters and I'm
a huge fan of Ghostbusters I was GNA
marry Ean Egon Spangler Like This Is My
Jam um so I would say Martin Freeman um
because I feel like he really in capsul
he really captures The Lovable innocence
of Rey and you need that I feel like
Benedict Cumberbatch um can certainly do
the high intellect that Harold RIS
brought in the original I feel like
Dwayne Johnson takes no crap The Rock
takes no crap from anybody so I feel
like he would be a wonderful uh Winston
type character funny and No Nonsense um
and Robert Downey Jr is essentially our
next Bill Murray I mean if you look at
his sarcasm and the way that he plays
things I really feel like that would be
a reboot to honor the original wow
interesting all right guys what do you
think well I love seeing Trisha's team
up there but it looks insane I I agree I
cannot imagine the Rock and Robert
Downey Jr and Benedict Katch and Martin
Freeman in the same movie and in the
same scene it would be amazing but
they're kind of especially RDJ and The
Rock they they're Stars so I can't
imagine them working together they all
they're kind of too different in they're
the two highest paid actors in Hollywood
right now and that shows the value that
they bring I can't even imagine these
guys in a room
together like I mean here's the thing I
love all of them every single one of
them and I think that I would definitely
watch this movie but I have never really
seen any of them really interact with
each other besides Freeman and
Cumberbatch right who are amazing of
course those two I can imagine together
uh but Benedict it's funny you know I
had a thought like when I started
casting this I'm like Benedict
Cumberbatch and then I was thinking no
he's just I think he's almost a little
too stiff so he'd be sort of like the
Egon guy right he's an amazing actor and
we've seen in the imitation game how
well he does high intellect and I really
feel like if you're going to be the
Ghostbusters it can't be all funny times
and action because you need the people
to run the PK meter you need that this
feels like a weird dream I had this
movie it would be a really really
awesome dream a very very cool what do
you think of Alicia um I thought Alicia
was good let me can I see the image
again just to make okay Joe M Michael
paa and Bobby monah while we're bringing
that up my I I think this is a good cast
for sure I think this would make a solid
movie I wouldn't say it's the Dreamcast
only because some of those guys don't
have a great movie track record got the
star with Channing Tatum so that's why
you can afford to cast people who who
deserve more of a chance on screen and
have that great comedic talent because I
think if you're weighing it too much
with too many stars then it becomes it
becomes a problem is it a rock movie is
it an RDJ movie and also with the female
version of Ghostbusters I know they said
very specifically they didn't want to
recast those main male roles because
they don't want it to be compared to the
original so I feel like if they were
going to do a male Ghostbusters they
wouldn't want to substitute people for
the original characters that they just
want to start a fresh so it's a
completely new I'm not saying recast the
characters but definitely keeping those
same archetypes I think is a solid
formula that shouldn't be messed with
and Bobby moan I think he's hilarious in
The Lonely Island videos he's great on
SNL but did you see Staten Island summer
just his his movie track record right
now now that's why he deserves a better
movie with a great script I agree he
deserves a great movie but I wouldn't
chance him on the next Ghostbusters it's
to high stakes I feel like there's too
many comedic actors and then only one
straight guy and I feel like I mean I
would watch this movie but I also feel
like Joel mccale can he's awesome but he
can also be a little one note sometimes
but I think he yeah he has that great
sarcasm that he can do and and I'd love
to see him do some more action like he'd
be great and I would say again kind of
the same thing as Bobby Mahan with Joel
really funny on community movie track
record not so good there's merry FR
Christmas and you know just just not so
great it's gonna be the new X Files yeah
okay all right let's see kloe's list i'
LED your thoughts on Khloe as we wrap
this out uh and Khloe's list was for
those listening Chris Pratt John krinski
Donald Glover TJ Miller Alicia and
Trisha thoughts on hers I almost cast
Donald Glover in mine because I was
thinking about him my thought against
him was maybe a bit too young so I was
trying to cast them all kind of a
similar age right right I almost went
old first too I was gonna put like
Nathan fillian and I was gonna do all
these different guys and then I decided
you know like Hollywood would want a
younger cast so I kind of went a little
bit younger yeah any issues I'm not
hearing issues
um do I win sorry so TJ Miller here's
what here's what I'll say against TJ
Miller I do think he's hilarious in
Silicon Valley absolutely um he's a
little bit Russell Brand for me and what
I mean by that is he does one thing very
well and it will get overplayed very
quickly and and I'm just saying that
that's my guess um but based on what
I've seen him do he it's a very very
strong character that his sense of
Comedy is in a very Russell Brand way um
but I feel like it could also be a very
negative that that coin can flip very
quickly and I like what John krinski is
doing now where he's moving away for the
comedies we just saw the trailer for 13
hours directed by Michael Bay and that
looks like even though it's a Michael
Bay movie it looks fantastic it looks
like he's it's a very strong dramatic
role for him so I'd love to see him do
more of that instead of going back to
Comedy so so you like my cast so I think
John krinski should be more dramatic
than comedy I would also say to chlo's
cast who are your
scientists oh who are my scientists um I
would probably I would love to see TJ
mil Oh Oh you mean like oh the scientist
in the thing well in yeah in in go who
would play the Egon and the ray who were
the I think I would probably like to see
TJ Miller as a scientist because I I
feel like he would be kind of really
funny because he's he's sort of a
slacker but it' be really funny to see
him be super super smart yeah exactly to
see him as a sonant and then um let me
think uh uh possibly John krinski I
would think maybe okay I would think
these guys all right or Don gluer either
this this is tough my catchphrase uh
Miss movies anything you need to add I
feel like there probably wasn't much
lying there it's just a casting um you
know what I got into looking up like the
highest paid actors cuz we had mentioned
that and Robert Downey Jor is the
highest paid actor currently this year
with Dwayne The Rock Johnson is a close
second right no he has the next actor on
that list is Jennifer Lawrence followed
by Vin Diesel La diesel V diesel beat
the Rock I'm soad he's
terrifying he could just like look at
somebody and they'll give him money so
and there's also a statement out today
from Ivan wman about this Ghostbusters
being null and void so he's completely
saying this isn't true so this is a
complete waste of time we can make it
absolutely not it here Ghostbusters
isn't happening now well maybe he'll
change his mind once he hears these
casts all right what if we're the ghost
he has to see the image of my cast all
right time ready I'm making my ruling
and uh this was legitimately tough
because I actually think there's there's
something fun to all of them but based
on the points and based on the prep and
based on the fact that everyone said as
it's not I don't think it's fair to
throw one out because it's ridiculous I
feel like everyone was sort of really
excited by yours even though it's sort
of impossible but what put me towards
the over the edge to give Trisha the
point point is I like I like the
breakdown you did on the on the smart
people and the comedic people which I
feel like you guys brought to last and
while you're right and I was you're
right you don't want to make it the same
she did verify that she doesn't want to
be the same she wants the archetypes and
I think if you're going to make a
Ghostbusters movie you got to borrow a
little bit the archetypes and you need
that Benedict straight stiff a little
bit you need the Egon would be insan
play I would watch
it so as ridiculously impossible as it
probably would be I think not going to
let that be the lack of a point so
Trisha gets the point unicorn of a movie
as a huge Ghostbusters fan if that's the
only point I get today I'm satisfied you
got it satisfied all right round
two uh Rogue Nation Mission Impossible
came out I loved it it was really fun I
thought it's I'm still debating if it's
my favorite it might be but I I had a
lot of fun with it everyone didn't get
to see it so we couldn't argue that
really here um but I also thought that'd
be kind of hard because it's really good
so instead uh in order to talk about
Mission Impossible since we want to
support that and I support good action
movies like that happening we should see
more of them smarter ones um each
Mission possible clearly had its own
distinct visual style and a different
director and so Tom Cruz has already
confirmed that they are developing
Mission possible six and every time they
pick some new hot fun director um so
movie Mike 80 asked us who should direct
the next mission impossible movie MI6
I'm sure will happen very quickly uh
let's assume they're going to do a new
director again someone different who
should they pick and this time we're
starting with you Chloe uh who would
your choice be uh I absolutely love
Duncan Jones I think he's brilliant and
I think he's sort of an upcoming
director he did Moon and everybody loved
the hell out of moon and then he just
did and I'm totally spacing on the name
source code source code thank you um so
he's doing Warcraft he's doing Warcraft
next so we'll see how how well that one
turns out um I have High Hopes because I
really love dcan Jones I think he's got
an amazing vision and I think he's got a
really good personality I think he's got
a sense of humor and I think he's
incredibly smart with the stuff that he
does so I think he could take Mission
Impossible and make it even smarter if
that's possible interesting Trisha
what's your pick I'm gonna go with Jos
Weeden he has such a great history of
fun and layered and multi-dimensional
action content I mean everything from
puffy the Vampire Slayer to Firefly to
more recently Avengers um great track
record really really fun stuff I feel
like it would be a very different feel
than the other Mission Impossible movies
which is what they're always looking for
and that's why Tom Cruz chooses a new
director for every Mi film um and I
would also say yeah it's great that he
hasn't worked with Tom before and I feel
like that will add a layer of a
completely new feel also this may end up
being the last mission impossible series
and to close out a series I feel like
you need something with heart and I feel
like that's something that Jos does
really well okay Alicia what your pick
well uh Tom Cruz I mean he is very
involved as a producer he's not just an
actor he's also a producer just for the
hell of it he is involved with every
step of the process and he loves to work
with people he's worked with before
people he feels feels comfortable with
so I'm choosing Doug Lyman who we worked
with on Edge of Tomorrow Edge of
Tomorrow was one of my favorite films
from last year I think it deserved to
make much more money than it did it's an
underrated film it's got great action
sequences it's got uh humor it's got
heart and it's got a little bit of
romance and they're all elements that
you see with the mission impossible
films plus Doug Lyman also directed The
born identity so he's very used to the
Spy genre as well as Mr and Mrs Smith so
I would love to see instead of Doug
Lyman do Edge of Tomorrow 2 which is the
rumor and I think Edge of Tomorrow was
just a nice self-contained story I'd
love to see him work with Tom again but
on Mission Impossible six because you're
right each of the movies do have a
different feel and that's why they have
a different director but they still have
the overriding tone of the spy movie and
that is why he is a great director for
this one that's my first retort was
going to be but Doug lyman's busy doing
Edge of Tomorrow Too instead of that
yeah thoughts let's hear the fights why
uh why not the other two okay my my
thoughts for Doug Lyman is that I would
worry that it would be Edge of Tomorrow
2 disguised as a Mission Impossible film
I feel like we've seen that movie before
it was very good but let's see something
different Edge of Tomorrow is a Sci-Fi
and Mission possible is a spy film so
they're going to be completely different
completely different and you did say
he's made through spy films yeah so he's
great at that genre and yeah Tom really
likes to work with people we've worked
with before oh shoot I don't really let
me think about this cuz I really did
like edge of tomorrow um I do feel like
there was it was lacking in a little
there a little bit of complexity and I
think that mission impossible is such a
straight sort of franchise that it kind
of really needs an injection of
personality and you know interesting
stuff so you know I would almost go more
Jos Weeden but even that I feel like I
love Jos but he's almost over the top
silly and I feel like there needs to be
sort of a middle ground right and that's
that's why I would go with Duncan Jones
so my argument against Duncan Jones
would be that he only has source code
and moon were both really good but other
than that he's only done a short film I
believe he has a short and then Warcraft
coming up which none of us have seen if
this is going to be the mission
impossible to potentially close out the
series is that true we you look that up
for me well Tom Cruz says he'll do this
character till he's 90 so it may they
said that it was going to be the one the
last one Tom also says he's doing Edge
of Tomorrow Too and yeah every Mo he
still says he's making a Top Gun too um
so Tom has a lot of he very ambitious
Top Gun too is actually happening I'm
excited about that well and he's a very
busy guy and uh you know he's he's
starting to get up there in his Action
Hero roles uh starting to get up there
in age ofit so we don't know we don't
know but I just feel like if this were
to be the mission impossible to close it
out I feel like we'd want someone who
has more than two films under their belt
well I love Duncan Jones because moon is
one of my favorite fils but he has such
a great style that I think works so well
with an original concept I I hate when
you get these Indie directors who are so
talented and then you kind of force them
into a franchise movie where they don't
actually get that much opportunity to
show style like each of the mission
impossible films feel slightly different
but they still all are cohesive as a
series they're not like a crazy sci-fi
you know indie film amongst it so you
need the big action sequences splashy I
mean he's got to keep topping himself
Tom Curry so to close out and then
what's your final thoughts on Weeden
before we because I want to go down the
line here Sweden I mean I I feel like uh
he's great with with Avengers and Buffy
when he has the whole team to play off
against each other but I he he's more
like splashy CGI silly fun mindless
entertainment at times although I do
like his humor I'm going to get hate for
that I Firefly popcorn great Summer
Films but I love the Mission Impossible
movies because as you said Andy they're
really smart and they have this this
whole complex story behind them he could
do it for sure I just kind of Imagine
him working with home just it seems like
a strange compan that's why be so
fascinating it'd be something completely
different I think Jos is really good and
what he does um I don't know I if he
would be the best choice of director for
it I think he'd be an interesting choice
of director but there's no guarantee
that that film would turn out well I
feel like there's too many different
variables that wouldn't end up working
out I feel like there's never a
guarantee I got I
got it's too complex for him and sort of
this too silly I get your and then just
give me one last closing for why you
think Jones is going to give us the best
one I think Jones as a new director I
think it's cool to give these films
these huge films to new directors and
see what they can do and um I think that
I mean there is definitely a fear that
the studio will be like well this is how
you should do it but I think Duncan
Jones vision is strong enough that it's
gonna supersede that and then Trisha
final Thoughts From You final thoughts
on Jos Sweden I think he has a history
of just killing it throughout the years
and I would love to see him tackle this
franchise time I miss movies anything to
add while I
my not I do uh JJ Abrams directed the
third mission Impossible film that was
his first feature directorial debut wow
so just wanted to put that up
there Chloe does the victory
dance first live action as well no I
will have to check on that yeah because
he did Incredibles Iron Giant and I
think this was before because he only
did this in Tomorrowland Jason's nodding
I believe that's true but not his first-
time movie but first time feature as a
live action all right uh
based on the arguments based on the
arguments I think I'm going to go with
chy yes oh my it was close but I think
what you said is you you did it the
smart you sort uh two complex for Lyman
and Su silly with weed and someone in
the middle and someone new those are the
things that ultimately sold me uh based
on the arguments um and you both sulex
by the way it is but boom that that was
uh that was that was a close one for me
you were close I think they did both
knock you out for Weeden but it really
came down to you two and then it was
just about we've seen him do it a bunch
something new with a new voice was what
I think was the strongest argument
that's the point I got one I'm happy I
do it was close cuz I do I do want to
personally I do want to see him do that
instead of edge tomorrow to because I
agree Edge tomorrow if you haven't seen
it see it it's fantastic it's great um
but uh don't make a sequel it was good
enough as a one movie round three
they're doing it and you were correct
that wasad first I thought all right
round three Kevin uh molison asked the
fun this fun question in honor of the
new Mission PA movie so fight number
three what's the best movie starring Tom
Cruz Tom Cruz's best movie best movie
starring Mr Cruz who I'm a huge fan of I
think he's a great movie star yeah uh
and so Trisha what's your thoughts okay
well I'm so excited that you said
there's going to be a Top Gun too
because my choice is Top Gun um it is a
movie that completely encapsulates the
80s in one film for us it's super iconic
to the point where people can recognize
it by just saying one word you say
Maverick you say Iceman people know
exactly what that is the soundtrack was
to die for um people are still singing
those songs and using them over and over
and I feel like it it really made a huge
difference on Cinema as we know it I
feel like the summer blockbuster was
really the way for the summer
blockbuster as we know it today was
paved by Top Gun and Jaws big go ahead
Alicia uh the best Tom Cruz movie is in
my opinion born on the 4th of July
because this was the movie that showed
what Tom Cruz could do as an actor in
the late 80s he was a big box office
star but he was had yet to prove himself
as an actor born on the 4th of July was
his first Oscar nomination of three and
Oliver Stone really cast him in an
interesting way because the way he
begins the film as Ron Ron kovic he is
very idealistic patriotic All-American
good guy who just wants to go out there
and fight for his country and that's the
kind of Tom Cruz we've seen before and
since but the transformation is what
makes this movie so special halfway
through the film you completely have
forgotten well into the film that it's
Tom Cruz which is hard to do because he
is such a famous actor he transforms in
the middle of the film he is a
heartbroken disillusioned man you feel
so sorry for him he comes back from the
war suffering and he doesn't know
whether it was worth it he doesn't know
if his country lied to him and that and
he has Redemption so it's such a great
transformation rewatched this recently
and I know everyone talks about platoon
as being Oliver Stone's best Vietnam
movie but I think Born in the 4th of
July has so much and I think it's
actually quite underrated because of the
way it looks at the suffering that these
young soldiers went through when they
came back from the war so that's why for
me born on the fourth of July is the
best Tom Cruz movie Chloe what's your
pick Jerry McGuire because I think Jerry
Maguire is one of the while Top Gun is
the movie that most people like us might
go oh Top Gun Jerry McGuire is the movie
that most of the US be like that's Tom
Cruz and it's so much associated with
Tom Cruz and and it is Iconic I mean
show me the money and and I mean it's
sort of just lived on throughout Cinema
as one of the best films that has been
made right um and uh Tom Cruz was it was
tough for me to really like Tom Cruz
because I always felt there was some
sort of stiffness about him and I felt
like Jerry Maguire actually made me
really like the guy and you know you got
to see more of his heart and his
personality and you know his soul so um
yeah I would I I uh I like Jerry McGuire
great so fight okay I would say Jerry
McGuire is certainly a great movie um
but did it really change Cinema I mean
it did a good job with the romcom genre
for sure but it did introduce anything
new into the world of movies also I
would say Jan L Nikki yeah of course
cute love Jon he's adorable for hey J
lip have you have you seen him lately bu
on Twitter yeah exactly yeah he's still
too he's ripped um he is he's like an
MMA fighter yeah we're there there's my
argument Jerry Maguire Jerry McGuire nck
not letting that sway my argument keep
going but yeah so I would say did it
really do anything to change the romcom
genre or leave its impact on Cinema
history enough to say that it's one of
the greatest movies of all time also
there are certainly memorable scenes and
moments in that movie but with Top Gun
you remember the whole thing every scene
is a memorable scene that volleyball
scene come on I don't remember it that
well you don't remember the volleyball
scene that inspired thousands of gifts
across the internet Bel Kilmer like look
it's it may be a taste thing so astion
movies are fun for me I like action
movies okay um but I prefer sort of a
study on a person right and I feel like
Top Gun didn't really it's not really oh
my God it's the biggest character Arc
ever he's on a journey to find himself
no it's big a character Arc
let's hear you guys CRA on
that that scene in the VA Hospital oh
that sticks with you and it also has Tom
Cruz yelling penis multiple times he's
playing the penis game yes I think that
Tom Cruz his performance is amazing and
born on the fourth of July potentially
his best performance of his career but
the question is his best movie um and I
feel like it really is a character study
on him but as a downside to that the
rest of the characters in the film are
very two dimensional and kind of not
interesting so when we're looking at the
film as a whole I don't know that it
would be the best film while I do agree
that it is Tom Cruz's disree that
they're they're two-dimensional I think
it's filled with great characters and
he's the centerpiece that brings it all
together Top Gun is an iconic film but I
don't know how much it actually changed
Cinema I mean it's a great action movie
and it maybe inspired a lot of action
movies afterwards because of its huge
box office success but you talk about
Blockbusters you got to talk about Jaws
and everything that came before to
you've got a love story you've got life
than death you have practical effects
action no CGI it's the best and then
thoughts on Jerry McGuire you two Jerry
McGuire oh it's it's one of the most
quotable films and really well written
by Cameron Crowe but in terms of a Tom
Cruz performance I feel like he
transforms a little bit but not enough
to make it stand out from all his other
filmography like I would choose
something like Magnolia before Jerry
McGuire although I love watching Jerry
McGuire that was the other thing I was
saying Magnolia Magnolia is very good as
well final Thoughts From You Against the
other two uh Top Gun is great for me
it's an action movie I like I I I
already did this where I I I prefer sort
of more about characters and I think
it's harder to make a movie without
action you know what I mean I to make an
enjoyable interesting movie without
action so that's that would be mine
against Top Gun and uh born on the 4th
of July I haven't seen so to be honest I
I I haven't seen it and I hadn't even
really heard that much about it until
today really I love it but that's
probably my own fault well and I would
kind final thoughts Trisha uh so final
thoughts arguing for Top Gun just yeah
in general I'm wrapping this W about to
close the gav about to wrap it up um I
would say uh what Chloe said about Bor
of 4th of July um the fact that a lot of
people don't know it and it is kind of a
sleeper film um I think speaks volumes
as far as movies that left their impact
on the world of Cinema um so I would say
for Top Gun that it certainly did that
I've said that before I I think that
it's a fantastic movie and that it
Encompass is that it's comprised of uh
action that's no CGI it was before CGI
was available so everything had to be
practical effects you're dealing with
fighter pilots and there's there's love
and there's a love story in it there's
death in it it's it's a little bit of
everything that you need in a huge film
and it made Tom Cruz a household
name time Miss movies any final thoughts
while I look at my notes absolutely um
one of these films has one best picture
which is born on the 4th of July which
also won best director Jerry Maguire
best supporting actor for Cuba Gooding
Jr um also nominated for best picture
and Top Gun got an Oscar for best
music Kenny amazing guess didn't Kenny
login didn't do the music One Long music
video Top Gun all right uh the question
is best movie starring Tom Cruz and I
think there were some fun choices here
but I think Alicia proved and sold why
born of the Fourth of July is the best
movie
and I
definitely I haven't seen every it's not
don't be ashamed there's a lot of movies
sometimes you got to catch up on but
she's right BN the for July is a
fantastic movie check it out they're all
fantastic movies uh but it really you
the things you said were just spot on
Tom Cruz just that is what showed he can
act like and it's like you don't expect
him to do a movie like that so all those
things you said I think just Pro uh and
at least she gets the point maybe I
maybe I need to rewatch it I will
rewatch I will uh round four
Mission Impossible is the fifth movie
based on 1966 TV uh based on the 1966 TV
show so uh Aces Tour 2010 on Twitter
asked us what star would you like to see
remake an old TV show as a movie so name
the star name the show we're going to do
quick pitches and then we'll we'll
respond and this time we're starting
with you Alicia all right one of my
favorite uh TV show to film adaptations
recently has been 21 Jump streak I love
the action comedy hybrid so I was
thinking on that those lines because I
was looking at other sci-fi or spy TV
shows that haven't been made into films
and I was like H nothing really stood
out to me so how about we bring back
night
rer starring the guy that can can pull
off uh talking to a tree Chris Pratt wow
it would be really funny to be
interesting um Chris Pratt has the the
wit he has the charm and he has the the
action chops as well and then for the
voice of Kit David
Hasselhoff get Lord and Miller involved
if they're not too busy with the they're
not bu little movie and then have that
same irreverent humor and I think it
could be really really fun huh inter I
like the addition of Hoff as Hof as the
car wow awesome Chloe what year was
everybody born in what what year well
okay what what decade were you Bor now
were were we is this totally rude like
okay 80s 80s ' 80s okay 80s yeah so uh I
don't know if you guys grew up with
Nickelodeon shows like I did yes um do
you guys remember The Secret World of
Alex Mac I remember it but I was more of
a Clarissa Explains It All which was the
show that Alex Mac like kind of replaced
which was a great show she was T1000 she
that's right she was so um she which we
joked about in a trailer that's how I
actually remember that so I want to see
Alex Mac again because it was such a
beloved show I went through all these
different 90s shows and saw like thought
about which ones would be best made into
a film and so I went with secret uh
secret life or Secret World of Alex Mack
because it has the biggest I feel like
the premise is something that you could
morph into like a really cool film and
Alex Mack would be Emma Stone H um and
uh the reason that I chose a 90s show
over an 80s show is because we have so
many 80s remakes and it's time for the
Next Generation to step in and start
making remakes get those remakes earlier
have an idea got it love it Trisha
what's your pick I'm going with Quantum
Leap um because it's awesome um but I
will say more than that um I'm going
with quantum leap uh starring Jason
baitman and the reason that I picked uh
Jason baitman is because I think that he
has that that very Earnest kind of G
whiz I think he does that very well that
you need in Sam and I picked Quantum
Leap because there is so much potential
for a huge Blockbuster film here I mean
how we saw in Forest Gump he meets Elvis
he does all these amazing things
throughout history it's that times in
Infinity for Quantum Leap because it's
time travel we're dealing with time
travel we're dealing with fixing the
problems of History we're dealing with
hilarious awkward situations and a
completely lovable character um there
haven't been any movies in Hollywood
that I've seen in the last I don't know
5 10 years that have kind of had all of
those elements in one and I feel like
it's a movie it's not a movie we need
it's a movie we
deserve all right guys what do you think
I never watched Quantum
Le so sorry for you l never that
interested in it what what I missed a
lot of the 80s shows like I'm least
familiar with night rer CU it's such an
iconic show right and I know kit and I
see kit at all the conventions we're
buddies now um I think that idea is
interesting but I think the show wasn't
really strong enough it had four seasons
of between
2 episodes so definitely wasn't a
failure no I'm not saying it was a
failure I just think it
was that many episodes I don't know if
the premise of the show is strong enough
to create a really interesting I mean
this is going to be like a Blockbuster
movie right so be really fun comedy it
go well but it could also just be
terrible and that's the same for a lot
of films right a lot of remakes but I
feel like this one has more potential
for failure just because it doesn't feel
like I mean it's a guy and a t talk I
think everyone said that about 21 Jump
Street like how is this going to be a
movie with Channing Tatum and Jonah Hill
and could have gone very poorly luckily
didn't it didn't so I love the idea of a
night rer I love that show I think your
casting is amazing my problem with
bringing back night Ridder is because of
today's technology it's just not
relevant we have cars that can drive
themselves now we have voice recognition
and AI made more relevant well it's
something everybody has when when Aunt
Sally has a car that already
hasar and Tesla that drives itself down
the highway which is what they're well
Tesla I think is close to doing that
right yeah well exactly that's
technology we have now so watching a
show about a car that your Aunt Sally
drives unfortunately just isn't as good
now as it was then I loved it in the 8S
I great but the tech now blows it out of
the water no no I think the I'm not
talking about we're using the same car
from the show the car but but AI exist
great thing about well that's the great
thing about movies is when you can
comment on what is happening in today
today's
society going to turn this car a
ridiculous machine it's going to be like
the Inspector Gadget of cars and that's
going to end up being it might end up
being like a gimmick just because well
and if we if we go so far as to say okay
it's not just the tech that makes the
car cool it's it has a personality and
it's a human then we're getting into
Herby loed territory and that was not a
great movie so that's tell me more about
your Quantum Leap because no one's
hitting on but I just need to hear a
little bit more about what that is um as
a movie so Quantum Leap it's a it's a
buddy comedy that uses time travel to go
back in time I know you ladies haven't
seen it but basically what happens is
Sam uh goes back in time and is
constantly put in different situations
where he needs to fix things that happen
throughout history I know the basic
premise but what would the movie be
would it just be him just traveling
three ti no I'd say uh I would say that
we would how many times does he go
through in a movie how just give I would
say we would pick one big Epic Journey
it would be one big Epic Journey that
he's dropped into in the beginning it's
his character figuring out why he's
dropped into this what he's supposed to
do I mean it's kind of like missed the
video game missed in the beginning where
you're have no idea and you go on the
hero's journey with him to find out what
his task is overcome and accomplish that
task meanwhile the whole time we're
doing this accomplishing task it's
sci-fi it's Holograms it's hilarity um
and a really lovable main character and
then they do something that's so amazing
that it changes history before we're
dropped back into Life As We normally
are or we could follow the television
show and be dropped into something
complet PE isn't that it's really it's
really hard to argue with you because
you're so
enthusiastic she is um sometimes I'm
enthusiastic about very bad ideas so
keep that in mind here's the thing I can
see Quantum leak being a great movie so
it's the forest sci-fi Forest G it is
the most expected out of all of the ones
that we're talking about I feel like
Quantum Leap would be made before any of
the other ones every time they mention a
rumor of it people go not but I think
with Alex Mack which is a kind of
obscure thing for you know I think that
it's going to be able to be marketed to
younger kids and younger kids would
really enjoy the story and I think that
the people who are nostalgic would enjoy
the story and I think there are so many
things that you could do with it it's
sort of an environmental story give me
something what would you do with it um
okay so I mean let's see so Alex Mack so
you guys are familiar with the premise
turns into a puddle because she is uh
she's essentially radioactive right she
has this weird sort of power and the
thing is since she's so relatable as a
character as opposed to these like x-
men and crazy superheroes she's just a
girl like a teenage girl that got given
this power so I feel like it would be a
pretty uh fun sort of simple story where
she uh sort of falls into this weird
situation she has to figure out how to
fight this giant Corporation that's
maybe dumping terrible stuff into uh you
know a river and she has to sort of I
feel like there's it's a pretty simple
story that you could do but you could do
so much more fun stuff with it and
having Emma Stone would really just amp
up everything and comedy okay it sounds
like a Nickelodeon film like a film that
Nickelodeon would make for Their
audience and and I love Emma Stone uh
but now in her career I I don't know
whether she would do that kind of film
she's going so well with drama and you
know Woody Allen films I just can't see
her going
back can we just make her do it it feels
like a smaller like a smaller film not
not a big Blockbuster well and I just
drama and I feel like another superhero
origin story where oh I was in a
chemical spill and now I have powers and
I don't know how to deal with that I
feel like we've seen that movie plenty
lately well oh darn it I'm going to try
and make it ruling cuz there's that was
that was a complicated one but miss
movies anything you'd like to add while
I'm pondering there's a few things um
Quantum Leap came close to being
cancelled in its third season but then a
letter writing campaign actual letters
written on paper with pens brought it
back for two more seasons um your Secret
World of Alex Mack was the TV debut of
Jessica Al so that's
interesting Dam it Night Rider has had
two reboots team Night Rider which was
only there for one season and then Night
Rider just they came back and decided
Well let's just call it night rer maybe
that'll work nope one season and that
was it so that's how it goes the
underdog win so I'm stuck between two
I'll open up my cards sometimes the
audience likes to know where my why I'm
making the call uh I think I think
Quantum Leap and Night Rider have an
interestinger debate no offense no it's
okay and so the where where I'm stuck is
I think you're there's something really
fun about it uh because that show is
great I'm still not clear on what the
movie is but I know that wasn't really
the task and then yours is interesting I
think they're being hard up because
you're clearly arguing for a comedy
about night Ridder um with Chris Pratt
like in 21 drum Street and I think
that's how you probably could pull that
one off if you're GNA do it so I like
both of
these what took me over the edge is the
casting and I think you had better
casting and so I'm going to go with Lea
night one point to Alicia so that's two
points for Alicia one point for Chloe
one point for Trisha moving in to round
five oh boy tough this tough competition
in honor of vacation uh reboot of the
sequel of the national Leons vacation uh
which is opening this weekend we want to
ask what's the best Road Trip movie uh
and this comes from Dave at weird4 on
Twitter who asked us this what's the
best Road Trip movie and we're starring
with you Chloe there are a lot of great
road trip movies uh I went ahead and
said Little Miss Sunshine because uh it
was one of my favorite movies the year
it came out and I was totally obsessed
with it it's really hard to write an
ensemble movie um and they managed to do
it with a lot of love humor I mean I was
riveted the whole time wanting to see if
they made it to the pageant like the the
acting the performances were all amazing
across the board and that's really
difficult to get in an ensemble film
great insem film Trisha what's your pick
I picked Planes Trains and Automobiles
um you've got some top tier comedy
talent in there it's a classic and if
you're looking for a movie that is a
road trip movie that is it is about
transportation we have every type of
Transportation in this film um so I I
think if you're going to say the best
Road Trip movie um that certainly has to
be up there there's natural there's very
relatable obstacles that the guys are
dealing with it's a situational comedy
so you mean you're laughing at their bad
luck the entire time but it's things
that we all do like hailing a taxi cab
or you know it's and so I feel feel like
the fact that it's not super overthe
toop in what the guys are having to deal
with makes it a movie that everyone can
just love and makes that that perfect
balance Alicia I'm going to go with a
classic and it's a movie that still
holds up and one that changed the game
for road trip movies Easy Rider 1969
this is the landmark counterculture
movie it was the Indie movie which made
$60 million at the box office it showed
Hollywood that they could they could
look to these smaller experimental films
and make money from them it also helped
to spark the American New Wave which was
the whole wave of new generation of
young filmmakers in America in the 70s
and early 80s it also won at Dennis
Hopper the first film prize at the can
film festival but most importantly well
actually before that I'll say it's got a
killer soundtrack it's fun to watch it's
a great Mythic uh Western in a way
Western on Wheels uh motorcycle Journey
throughout America it spoke to a whole
generation but one of the major reasons
I love it so much and it did another
reason why I changed the game was
because of Jack Nicholson this was a
small role for Jack Nicholson but he
stood out so much that it gave him his
uh supporting actor Oscar his first ever
Oscar and he's someone who's won three
so he's incredible and that made
Hollywood take notice of Jack Nicholson
from there he did five E easy pieces and
then he went on to have a brilliant
career so for all of those reasons and
for the fact that I watch ay Ryder at
least once a year and I still love it
I'm going with easy Ryder easy right wow
this is going to be a tough fight I
apologize I'm bringing up the cast of
LMA Sunshine because it's such a large
cast that I won't remember all them
that's
why and I've got my notes okay so yeah
this I mean let's let's keep it on the
task of why is it the best Road Trip
movie CU let's not just say best movie
why is it the best Road Trip movie
what's makes it iconic cuz these are
three great movies so this is you're
making it tough on me but we'll start
again back uh to Chloe I guess you can
start us what compare to the other two a
road trip is a metaphor for a person's
changing right and this I mean a road
trip is a perfect setting for character
arcs and you don't get more character
arcs than you do in Little Miss Sunshine
everybody starts at one place in the
film at the beginning and then
completely ends up in a different place
at the end of the film you fall in love
with all of the different people um and
you watch this poor boy lose his dream
of becoming a and it breaks your heart
and and there's just so much
relatability you can you can find uh
someone in the cast that you relate with
the most and I feel like it just speaks
to everybody and as a road trip film you
know you get to see a lot of America
it's beautifully shot it's cinematically
gorgeous so that's why that's there's my
argument I I love that movie I think
it's a great movie I would argue against
the fact that you can relate to every
character I think that the characters
were a little bit quirky and a little
bit out there what makes it so funny but
one you can find somebody related okay
yeah that's what I'm like the characters
are so out there that it's hard to make
that assumption um and as far as uh the
character Arc I agree with you a road
trip is 100% about a character Arc which
is why when you look at Steve Martin's
character in plane Trains and
Automobiles he literally does a full 180
and I I don't know if everyone has seen
it but spoiler alert everyone go see it
everyone everyone go see it spoiler
alert it is a full like the opposite
extremes that's the point and the lesson
of the film so as far as taking that
character Arc I feel like road trip
movies in general need that to be a
solid road trip so I don't know that you
can say that's an advantage there for
Little Miss Sunshine yeah they
definitely need the journey and I think
all three of our films have the
character journey and they also need to
show off the landscape and iconic
America and that is very much shown in
Easy Rider and Roger Ebert did a review
of easy R of four out of four stars
saying that it changed the whole genre
of the Road Trip movie because it showed
that it could be a legitimate art form
so not only is it fun to watch does it
have all the elements of Road Trip movie
but it actually paved the way for things
like Little Miss Sunshine and Planes
Trains and
Automobiles calling it you all had your
points uh Miss movies thoughts anything
you need to add or can I call this you
can call it it's tough because I love
all these movies and I really really
really really love your movie but I
think Alicia gets it just out of like of
a
I agree with your decision I would have
given it to I was I was trying to find
some holes but your clothes are really
closed it and I you got that point that
was great but PL strange automobiles see
that movie guys what a great movie like
I cry at the end every time it's so good
it's a great holiday watch it around
Thanksgiving Thanksgiving movie yes
great Thanksgiving movie probably the
best told me about Thanksgiving it's
such a good time those aren't pillows
round six
yeah uh so our for our final round here
Hugh Jackman has asked fans on Twitter
this last week to help decide how his
15-year-old 15-year career as Superhero
Wolverine should come to an end he
received over 10,000 retweets um so DJ
CH j17 on Twitter asked us for round six
pitch the final Hugh Jackman Wolverine
movie we want the basic plot a villain
and a title how do we want to see
Wolverine go out this is an epic one I'm
excited to hear this uh and we're going
to start with you Trisha okay I'm super
stoked about this um so this is roughly
based on the comic the Enemy of the
State Comics if you know any of the
Wolverine backstory um so I I it's kind
of Enemy of the State meets becoming
from Buffy the Vampire Slayer here's how
it works so Logan is brainwashed by
Hydra and goes on a killing spree
against all of his friends and allies um
you know just tearing everybody up and
Professor X and Magneto are like we need
to stop this however Professor X is like
no Logan's great there's a good Logan in
there we can bring him back back um
whereas Magneto is just like we can't
kill any more mutants this absolutely
has to end so they kind of team up but
you know are taking different means to
get there and just as Professor X is
able to bring Logan back all of the
adamantium is ripped out of his body by
Magneto and he dies so there's a super
dramatic thing it's so that's the
becoming Buffy the Vampire Slayer moment
um if you haven't seen that episode
watch it it's amazing um yeah yeah but I
mean so it's it's that it's so really
your villain is Logan your villain is
Wolverine which is a nice New Way for us
to see him I mean he's super badass so
we' make an amazing villain um and then
you get that drama and I mean it's going
to make everybody cry at the end when
she's finally like good Logan again and
then it all gets ripped out of its body
um and for the title I'm going to steal
uh I'm I'm going to steal becoming and
say the title is Wolverine becoming
Legend H nice oh boy all right good
start Alicia show all right my title is
simply Wolverine colon Old Man
Logan Old Man Logan is the one Old Man
River Old Man Logan is the storyline
that so many fans want to see and it's
also the storyline that Hugh Jackman has
teased multiple times but if you read
the comic series then you know that they
have Hulk hulks in there and Hawkeye and
all these characters that fox don't have
the rights too so much like the
Wolverine behind you take elements of
the different comic series and put it
together so mine also has elements of
enemy state so it's set far in the
future it's way past all the timelines
so far of X-Men Logan is living with his
family and he's vowed to put the claws
away you realize that through a series
of flashbacks and dream sequences that
he has been brainwashed in the past
captured brainwashed by Gorgon who is
the villain in this and tricked into
killing a lot of his ex-men so he's one
of the the last remaining X-Men he's
tormented by this and that's why he vows
to put the Clause away he's living with
his family but he's running out of money
so he accepts much like an old man Logan
storyline he accepts a delivery job but
it's not what it seems It's a way for
goorgen to get Logan away from his
family and he can take ultimate revenge
on him and kill his family Logan comes
that was pretty dark Logan comes back to
his house and he sees that his family
has been killed and he gets angry goes
out to find Gorgon meanwhile one of his
family members is still alive DC his son
so Logan goes off to fight Gorgan he
discovers that Gorgon is trying to
become a darker version of Wolverine big
fight kills him day comes to find his
father he's angry at his father because
he thinks that his father abandoned them
he comes to the aftermath of everything
he sees that Logan has gone against his
promise he's Unleashed his claw he's
killed everything he's then gone off
again by himself with a lot of grief so
dayon sees what gorgen was up to and
decides to become dark Wolverine and
that's where it
is does that make sense yes yes just
there was a lot I like it Chloe I did a
lot of research this is g to be
tough oh jeez okay so I'm not super
familiar with the Wolverine story lines
I'm just recently getting into Comics
right okay so here is my original story
about wolver
your own original story my own original
story okay so Wolverine uh he
essentially he's in a small town in
France right and um he has to he
basically really wants to help this
family help feed this family so he goes
and he steals a loaf of bread and he
breaks a window and he ends up going to
jail for about 19 years um so he's in
jail for 19 years he's uh miserable Miz
what no lay Miz
starts
what's is that the music D's done that
movie sry so okay I I don't know if I've
heard of lame Miss so he um he's in jail
he tries to break out and it basically
the sentence gets longer and longer and
essentially uh he basically makes this
enemy out of sabertooth right Sabertooth
is his guard right so he takes off uh
essentially saber-tooth lets him go he
has to go because it's been 19 years or
whatever so he runs off and he um he
essentially starts building his own
Factory he basically uh industrializes
the small town that he lives in right
got it okay uh and so what year are we
in uh my head let's go with future 2007
or something okay got it got it got it
um so while he's at this Factory this
girl uh Jean Gray uh so she gets fired
for no reason and he feels so terrible
about her getting fired that he agrees
to help her by taking in her daughter um
which is uh Jubilee oh okay uh so he
takes in Jubilee and basically raises
her as his own I I mean this story is
really long I can if you want there's
probably like a war at some point right
yeah yeah I mean obviously is singing I
love you so much you just gave the plot
of lay Miz you need to see lay
Miz I love you so much I'm like this is
a joke this is a joke she's kidding is
there any sing every plot point I'm not
even kidding no what every really you're
coming over my house we watching lame is
but lame kind want to watch it lame is
recast with the X-Men I mean cool have
another story where it's uh Wolverine
lives in an abandoned theater uh and he
lives under the theater okay sorry okay
continue I'll let you guys I'll let you
guys fight this you're or not and then I
thought this is brilliant Chloe you're
my fav throw it out we might want to
watch that don't throw it out you're
sing dance that's dangerous two Jackman
so that he could hurt someone with the
dance mve I'm sorry I spoiled the joke
too
early all right she sold it so
well I've never heard of lus I'm not
sure what you're talking about so fun
this is this is the best movie fights
moment ever all the points all the
points all right so we have uh the
musical Wolverine love it and then we
have Old Man Wolverine and we have Enemy
of the State Wolverine thoughts on which
ones excit you the most aside from your
own oh aside from your own um
lame lame sounds so awesome I'm very
surprised that went over so that was
great you just sold that I mean it is
it's a classic story it's a classic plot
that has been well she believed you the
whole time she really thought you also
didn't know she was doing that on
purpose that was my favorite part I love
that that that you I love it took me a
while to you thought she just did that
by accident that's what made me Crack
was that she's like you should see L Miz
I'm the most gullible person in the
world um but everyone's so confused uh
so we have uh we have lay Miz version of
uh of Wolverine we have Old Man
Wolverine and we have uh so what do you
think we should just go with lay I think
she should just get the point you know I
think lame M Wolverine is hilarious
that's absolutely hilarious that's my
okay I'm gonna have I'm going to take it
back last chance otherwise we're going
to go
with it Al um so does Logan actually die
in yours I was a little unclear no he
goes off to the sun I don't want to see
he just decides to stop being Wolverine
like what makes him just decide he's
done now he he stops being Wolverine at
the beginning because of what happened
in the past and that's the Old Man Logan
storyline so from he becomes Wolverine
again at the end when he's having the
big fight sequences and then he's really
upset at himself and off he goes and so
it could continue the adventures of
Wolverine with someone else if you
wanted to I just don't want to see
Wolverine die especially not Hugh
Jackman you love Hugh Jackman I think
you got to finish out the story likeable
guy that you just just want and and I
don't think they want to kill off
Wolverine completely because he's such a
loved character a Comics there's
multiple univers we can bring him back
later it's pretty cruel to kill a dog in
a movie and I feel like Wolverine's kind
of like he's a dog I don't know I feel
like I feel like and also question does
uh does Fox have the rights to Hydra no
so the reason that I only brought Hydra
in in the beginning which was another
thing I was going to bring up because
you're crossing a lot of Rights and
legal there too yeah well I'm I'm
sticking with Fox otherwise go for Hulk
and I'd go for Hulk ey I Tred oh I'm
sorry I thought you were bringing
everybody in I thought you had said that
um yeah I mean so you can tease Hydra
also there's many different hydra agents
you don't need to cast the same actors
you know much like we saw with Scarlet
Witch um you know you can you can recast
someone else or use a different Hydra
agent in because because they are
separate properties even though they're
Marvel they're completely separate well
that's what happens An Enemy of the
State that's the storyline it is Hydra
An Enemy of the State but that's there
is no Hydra though in this universe so
or are you creating a different are we
creating a fake
Hydra this
not we can't we can't use it at all even
because I mean Scarlet which was used
twice Quicksilver was used twice uh all
right so let's assum we can okay Jason's
shaking his head no in there but I'm
thinking as long as you do it
differently it's okay I think so I like
call at the idea the idea at the end
when he becomes dark Wolverine I think
that's kind of a cool okay so if we're
if we're going to if we're going to take
out Hydro we'll use another government
entity and we will just say that a
government entity that's put out there
to stop mutants in general all right I'm
calling I'm calling this one for sake
anything to add Miss movies yes I had a
little bit of prep before this so I knew
you know kind of the going and I had
written to Jason is that the plot of lay
M and I also want to make sure that we
don't confuse Enemy of the State with
the 1998 film Will Smith very different
you could match that one up too anything
else yeah that's all I got
okay very different here's where I'm
stuck that was really funny so funny I I
don't know if I can give you the point
for being funny that's fair so I'm going
based on year
two and I feel like they both sort of
wanted me over and do we really want him
to die no yeah and we don't want him to
be a v it's a mean way to go out oh but
that's the only way you I'm going to
give it to Alicia oh winner winner
winner chicken dinner up ahead by a lot
now
what that means is I'm going to give
Chloe aot and Trisha now we're doing a
quick speed tiebreaker here to see who's
make you're Beast to go into the final
round but this is going to be a tough
speed round because she's up by three so
uh yeah it's going to be a tough speed
round we're going to go to a quick
tiebreaker question before I do that
though I wanted to make sure I thanked
someone specifically these two posters
behind
us uh that was thanks to Calvin Hoskins
on Twitter uh that supercal thank you
dude for sending your awesome posters
we're going to put them on the wall the
rest of you you want to send posters
we're I'm just going to put an address
in the description of this episode go
ahead send us posters and toys we're
starting to collect think because
everyone wants to send us stuff like
sure we'd love to display your toys
prominently on our shows uh so just
thanks Calvin for that that was very
nice you to send a bunch of cool posters
and the rest of you um so this is a
tiebreaker this is for Trisha and Chloe
yeah and here we go tiebreaker question
we test this we wehe this earlier so you
guys know how this works uh whoever says
the answer first gets to choose that
answer the other person has to pick the
second oh there's music this is one this
is just one chance and then that you go
into our speed
round these two movies are in the
Bargain Bin which do you
buy Ace Ventura when Nature Calls or
dumb and dumber two D Ace Ventura when
Nature Calls you said dumb and dumber
two no I didn't say the whole title I
said D you said dumb and dumber two I
think you got to you got to go with what
you said
oh I think that's I'm I'm rolling that
that's over there
once you cuz otherwise that's not fair
to her you can't just change say one and
change it okay so I I you're done number
two so stay confident and you're asent
when Nature Calls part two uh so you
said it first you get to go first Trisha
ready time of the clock 15 seconds go um
Dumb and Dumber To because it's going to
make you recall all of the Excellence
that was the first Dumb and Dumber which
was such an amazing movie you could rank
it up there with me it's one of my top
three favorite comedies of all time so
just relating back to that is enough to
make it a better bargain Choice than
when Nature Calls you're arguing about a
movie that's not the movie that you
picked which is uh Dum Dumber one which
is a great film dumber dber two is a
different film and then a Ventura is an
amazing character who's fun to watch
throughout the film in any film because
it's Jim Carrey 5c rebuttal P 5 Second
rebuttal he is not great to watch in any
film Ace ventur when Nature Calls is a
perfect example of
that wow that's tough I'm going to call
Jason in to help me make this rolling on
the ti breaker and Miss movies I want to
call this fairly wrong movie I'm going
to call this fairly cuz I do think had
it I am going to go with Chloe yes but I
want to make sure I'm in this I'm in the
I'm not in a minority here I want to
make sure this is a fair battle Miss
movies based on the arguments who would
you have picked um I just didn't hear
enough about when Nature Calls
personally so I would pick
Trisha Chloe it says Chloe Jason all
right so I just there was a little it
was it was tough so I want to make sure
we take the right person in two to one
Chloe got the vote you're going to the
finals wow it's going to be a tough
speed round can we have another pay
break no no use it sadly we can't pause
this recording damn it we're going to go
very quickly though all right tiebreaker
uh is decided that does not give her a
point on the boards okay so the final
score here we have is four to one so you
need to you need to really get these
three in a row to to do this so they're
going to help me to make sure we're on
top of this let's C the speed round all
right oh tits sorry question one can I
say
tits tell me Hollywood's best George
George clany oh oh George
castanza okay I I guess I'll accept that
uh yeah it's a character okay we we
didn't Define it so I'll let you have
the character uh Clooney versus castanza
go 15 seconds George ceny is proven not
only is he a great actor but he's also a
great director I love to see him behind
the camera as well as in front of the
camera he's not just a good-looking guy
he can play a multitude of roles and
he's been on TV and he's been in movies
and he's just so damn Charming oh God
George castanza 15 seconds on the clock
and go ahead okay George castan castanza
is one of the most iconic characters
he's on Seinfeld he's loved and hated
simultaneously he's a polarizing figure
he's hysterical and everybody knows
about George castanza they quote him and
he will be quoted for the the rest of
Time 5 Second rebuttal he's only been in
one t sh it's cuz he's a
character you I did think you brought a
pretty good fight we should make a
Seinfeld movie Yes can we go back to
that one you did give a good valent
effort but Clooney gets the point that's
fair and I lost right is that I don't
think so not yet she needs to get all
the next ones right so Alicia gets this
next Point she wins correct if Chloe
gets the next four she goes to a
tierza so you need to get five in a row
Chloe it's it has been done or pretty
close to been done surprisingly so don't
rule it out okay and I'm not good Under
Pressure I know terrible these two
movies are playing on cable which D
should we watch Super Eight or8 Mile
Super Eight oh let's go eight I heard
Super Eight you have a minute to think
go ahead 15 seconds at the clock go
ahead okay Super Eight Is JJ Abrams love
letter to the movies that we grow up
grew up with like ET and The Goonies it
also had a great hitchcockian feel in
that it didn't reveal the monster till
much later it spoke to the nostalgic
part of of adults as being kids and also
love of movies I'm screwed okay uh 15
seconds go eight eight mile starred
Eminem and no one expected this movie to
actually be good but it was actually
fantastic I mean the whole story arc and
and sort of getting a look into Eminem's
life which is a Eminem is a character
that most people didn't take seriously
he's a character darn it 5sec rebuttal
he's a great actor but he's I mean he
was great in that film but he's not a
movie that I would rewatch over and over
again where I feel you add a little
leure I want to give you five seconds
anything else you want to add about the
movie cuz she did go off book it had
great music it had great characters and
great
acting I was waiting for you to bring up
the music I'm glad you did I'm going to
bring in uh Trisha you're going to help
me decide this Miss movies again I I
think you did Pro I think I'm going with
Chloe on 8 Mile and I I if you didn't
say the music you were going to lose but
you brought the music in which was a key
Point uh uh Trisha I I was going to go
with super eight uh because of the
throwback to Goonies and the throwback
to the movies we grew up with and so
miss movies you're the deciding vote
here who do you pick based on the
arguments I was I'm going to go with
Chloe miles still in okay I think you
did uh his throwback but was that a Pity
point a little bit more about the
performan and things I think you did
call and the music you did give me a
little bit more all right so she's still
in the
board next up Jesus come on tell me the
best movie with the word time in the
title time
bit time why do I go blank during this
um The Land Before Time okay Time
Bandits versus Land Before Time Time
Bandit is up first Chloe time 15 seconds
go ahead Time band is The Lovable movie
that still holds up there's amazing
characters there's amazing people
there's amazing effects they're all
practical effects and it well not all
but most of them are practical effects
and the characters and you have Terry
Gilliam who's an amazing ctor and and it
just all came together to make this one
great movie Lea 15 seconds lamb before
time I grew up watching the lamb before
time and I remember collecting all the
toys from Pizza Hut it spoke to me so
much the the Dinosaurs the characters
together the journey and and I feel like
it's it's something that colored a lot
of people's childhoods and it's it's a
loved movie I watch it again and I still
love it sorry so Terry gilam is mostly
made stuff for adults but finally made
something that everybody could enjoy and
it turned out to be fantastic separate
point so I'm going to let if you have
anything else to add you're allowed
really quickly one last point oh time
bands oh to B L yeah she just went she
didn't do her Buttle so I'm giving sure
it's fine I just think uh Land Before
Time is such a great childhood film that
I still love time balance is is fun but
it's actually kind of scary good not for
kids I went blank in my uh this is tough
I'm definitely going to activate you two
to help me with this one miss movies I'm
going to start with you this time based
on the arguments who do you think made a
better job it's Land Before Time all the
way so
see and I was going to say Chloe because
for Land Before Time you didn't mention
that it spawned all those sequels that's
what I wasit but the Pizza Hut toys was
solid still I would I would have gone
with Terry gilam and Chloe so you're so
it's up to
me I go to Chloe I give a little bit
more of the points and I while the Pizza
Hut toys was close based on the movie it
was close I love that movie but it was
it was on the fence for me wow she's
still in this you have to do two more
and that takes her to a tiebreaker so
you have to win three wow and I need to
pce number four my mouth is dry uh ready
ready here we go music music please if
we can hopefully play the music again
ready best movie best movie starring
Kirsten
Stewart American Ultra which hasn't come
out yet I will go with
um I will go with
uh on the right [__] okay so we have
American Ultra which is a trailer we're
going to base it on sure that's fair and
on the road and go ahead uh American
Ultra was first so you have to go first
I've seen a lot of American Ultra uh I'm
biased because my friend wrote it but
basically it's the first movie we're
going to see Kristen Stewart in where
she's actually has a really legitimate
interesting character really interesting
role and I believe that she's going to
pull out this amazing thing that we
haven't seen in her before I disagree
that we haven't seen it before because
she's in movies like on the road that
she has the acting chops I think
Twilight is the exception not the rule
when it comes to her career on the road
obviously based on the great Jack caroak
novel she pulled off that character
perfectly and talk about Road movies
that's a fantastic Road movie plus she's
two hands Jo I screwed myself wow
screwed myself careful don't make that a
j
people I shouldn't have like go ahead
last last second I think it's going to
be amazing to watch Jesse Eisenberg and
Kristen Stewart get together in this
really amazing uh comedy drama she went
up book I don't think you need it I
think on the road I think sadly on the
road on the road on the road takes it
you were so close but almost came from
behind Alicia takes another win on her
belt wow six to three to one wow that
was that was fun though she she's tough
all I could think of was Twilight and
I'm like can't see that can't say that
well I grateful to all of you uh for
doing a fantastic show I had so much fun
listening to you that was that was a
very hard one for me to do uh for to
judge cuz you all brought brought it so
thank you for taking it seriously and
bringing the heat fantastic job I want
to thank you all at home for watching
please go uh tell us in the comments as
always what you want to see uh what
fights you want us to do who you want us
to have up here and fight we listen to
you and obviously always subscribe on
iTunes and on YouTube if you're
listening there uh I want to thank our
panelist Alicia Malone Alicia Malone on
Twitter anything else you'd like to tell
the audience you can also find me on
YouTube movies are my jam that's my
title cool movies are her Jam check it
out uh and Chloe dystra at skyart on
Twitter anything else you'd like to tell
us about youtube.com/ skyart I'm YouTube
or I'm Sky Dart pretty much across the
board so come visit me cool please visit
her and then Trisha herburger at
thatgirl Trish grrl Trish thatgirl Trish
no I in the girl um or you can check me
out youtube.com/ nerdychick 5 yo Trish
that girl with the ey in the girl come
on this is the real that girl Trish can
you like hook her up with your Twitter I
feel so bad for that girl Trish come on
that girl Trish hook her up
uh didn't mean it start flame War that's
okay no it's not a flame War it's it's
intense intense feel battery that I have
F and on the fan cam thank you you did a
fantastic job Miss movies at Miss movies
thank you for stepping in here to help
us out thanks for having me did you have
fun of course awesome and I can't wait
to have some more of that fudge that was
so nice of you to bring uh and please
follow me on Twitter and Instagram and
all those things at Andy signor please
tell me how much you love or hate me
it's I love it all because it means you
care and that's the most important thing
to me
uh Jason JT thanks in the booth thanks
to everybody at home see you next week
bye guys bye
every every podcast we put on YouTube
comes with this Kick-Ass graphic listing
all the topics your favorite screen
junkies podcasters are talking about if
you click the topics you can skip around
and choose your own podcast Battle
Royale go ahead try them all if you
haven't already subscribe to screen
junkies on YouTube to join us for future
fights or if you prefer to listen on
iTunes click the logo to download an
audio version